[Applause]
we're just gonna keep doing it oh my
gosh your eyes in person are just like
next-level oh thank you yeah way to go
god yeah way to go so you you have been
married for six or seven years right yes
okay do you have any advice for Max and
Julian up there
first of all congratulations I mean what
an incredible story you know it's funny
because your story reminds me of like a
shot a song love is stronger than pride
and it's it's it's just your story gives
so many people hope to kind of put pride
aside compromise go at love
you understand what I'm saying man a man
that loves a date so what was your first
date like with your wife it was a lot to
take over so exactly that's what every
woman says yet when I tell this day so
my wife had was she basically told me
that this other guy was not her
boyfriend so I asked her about him and
she said no he's not my type
he's not my boyfriend he's never been my
boyfriend you're my type oh yeah agretti
was the first time she ever said that
yeah and I was like okay yeah so I think
I called it the day after and was like
okay so can we go out on like Tuesday
night she's like no okay oh just like no
reason just like now she's like no I'm
working I was like okay great well okay
I get it how about like Thursday
no I'm working this was like this I have
Monday off yesterday we'll go out and I
was like this okay
it's kind of hot she's bold I think I
think it worked
in hindsight it works yeah I'm excited
to work I think in the moment I was just
like kind of just taken aback like it's
she crazy yeah and I think I was drawn
to that I was definitely drawn to that
but yeah and then the first date we
actually we linked up during the day
because she was like I'm gonna go I'm
gonna work tonight but let's do
something during the day I was like add
a date sexy right so we went to this
like Vietnamese restaurant and we ate
and then didn't want it to end so I was
like what else could I do
what else could I do and she was sitting
there we were talking and we were
talking and she said to me can we get
the first kiss out of the way she got
like I'm feeling you and I'm telling you
right now if it's bad or if it's wack I
just want to go home and never see you
again we're still together
[Applause]
you're now she's your wife and after
seven years like this is the thing I
don't get and I could never date an
actor because I ain't seeing my man with
some other chick up on a filming like
now it's just for work like just go yeah
that is a different level of comfortable
first of all I am an artist and it is
acting sure he's always 100% acting she
just never got weird about it
you know and she's always said she's
always said cuz her girlfriends to this
day even to this day will see me they
see me make out with Kobe on Stumptown
and be like you know I don't know how
you do it I don't know how you do it and
she tells him the same thing every time
look he's never given me a reason yeah
to doubt so absolutely
[Applause]
are almost the same age they're similar
ages are your kids into performing like
you sadly yes okay me too it is it is
something that you probably I don't know
about you I tried to prevent it at all
cost in there's just no way around it my
my daughter who's three who she uh oh my
god was a one eyes she had her first
like Winterfest celebration and her
little preschool oh my god exactly
exactly I didn't know about this this is
a gym nobody told me about so they bring
out all the kids and my daughter was
dead center and she comes out and she's
looking you could tell she's looking out
for her mom and me and I'm like and so
I'm holding the camera she's not looking
over she's not looking over so I start
calling her nickname and then she gives
us like a Miss America wave are you
experiencing you said three years old
right yeah she's three
so I mean three n'ajjer right is that
been absolutely three days this is a new
term to me I didn't know this oh well
absolutely true yeah we have a three
year old boy girl boy okay and he just
destroys everything yeah like a
psychopath just like look just
everywhere that changes yeah it changes
hopefully but she like we couldn't
figure out who she was like for years it
because she's not exactly like my wife
she's not exactly like me she has you
know and I hate this term now because
they only use it for girls they people
call her sassy right and I'm like well
why don't we only use that term for
girls oh why is that for many guys yeah
I've never heard anybody that being said
it was one of those things where she I
realized that she's just like my aunt my
aunt Shanti's in DC she is
sweet as pie but she will cut you if you
cross her I think you hurt someone in
her family she will cut you
she came to set and we were doing a
scene on some town where I was like I
was a a car was being stolen and the
woman whose car I tried to chase after
the car and the woman whose car was
stolen started hitting me when I tried
to help her off the ground and my wife
had explained to her this whole story
about how dad was a superhero and this
was the princess and the thieves stole
princess his carriage and so exactly
she's created in this way so so my wife
I mean after the tank I get up and my
daughter says daddy why didn't why did
the princess hit you and I said and I
looked up and my wife was like I was
like because I'm trying to get her car
back and she was like where's the
princess I was like she's right here oh
she's gonna cut the press she went up to
the princess the actress it says you
don't hit my dad super hero and then she
crawled in my arms and hug me like what
do you want a unicorn I'll find one
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going